according to many polls Republican
presidential candidate Mitt Romney is
now basically tied with President Barack
Obama for Romney to win he's going to
need every stray vote he can collect
here are three ways it might win over
the ten to fifteen percent of
libertarian minded voters who want
exactly the same thing the GOP says it
stands for sharp reductions in the size
scope and spending of the federal
government Democrats and Republicans
alike pay lip service to cutting
spending but the gops entire identity is
predicated on the notion of smaller
government if Romney wants to carry
libertarians he needs to start talking
about cutting the actual year-over-year
totals that taxpayers shell out for
big-ticket items such as Social Security
Medicare and defense outlays on Medicare
alone have risen over 75 percent in
inflation-adjusted dollars since 2001
and Romney's calls for preserving and
protecting Medicare makes a mockery of
the idea that the GOP will be fiscally
responsible with MIT in the White House
defense spending is up more than seventy
percent real terms in the 21st century
and everyone is tired of us trying to be
the world's policemen libertarians
believe in a strong national defense but
like the majority of Americans they
don't believe that endless wars like the
ones in Iraq and Afghanistan will either
make a safer at home or bring peace to
foreign lands libertarians rightly fear
that Republicans want a sharply curtail
reproductive freedom expand the drug war
band whatever they consider pornography
and treat gays and lesbians as
second-class citizens nobody's asking
for lifestyle approval they just want to
make sure Romney and the Republicans
will respect our right to be left alone
the memory of george w bush in his big
government ways not to mention a great
LP candidate and former new mexico
governor gary johnson means romney and
his fellow Republicans will have to do
something that's almost unthinkable in
politics they will need to actually live
up to what they say they stand
for reason TV I'm Nicholas
you